hello everyone welcome back to the
couple Blanca Saga now as you know for
the past couple of videos during the
Capablanca saga i didn't know which
direction were gonna take however we're
gonna check up on a couple more
tournaments or do we go straight into
the match with last card now actually
thought about skipping the 1918
tournament of New York and going into
the match against Serbian Grandmaster
borislav course stich in 1919 in in Cuba
Cuba Havana but then I decided that we
really need to check out the 1918
tournament in New York then go to the
match with Kostich and only then go into
the World Championship match with
Emmanuel asker
now this is actually a game from round 3
I decided to skip a game from round -
it's a game capablanca played against
Roy terminal black it was a very nice
drawn game but not a lot going on so I
decided to skip it but game 1 we already
did game 1 from this tournament a year
ago on this channel it's cup of Blancas
famous game against fringe Frank James
Marshall where Frank James Marshall
unleashes the Marshall attack for the
first time so if you haven't seen this
game the first thing you will see in the
description below will be a link to this
game Capablanca versus Marshall so do
check it out if you don't check it out
you're not gonna be following up on your
vast knowledge in the proper way with
this New York tournament of 1918
so even feel free to pause the video now
and watch that video and only didn't
return to this video because this is a
game from round 3 in this game kappa
blanka faces jon stewart morrison and
silver strong player he's a Canadian
champion five-time Canadian champion and
he participated in three tournaments
that Capablanca also participated in in
interestingly Capablanca won all three
but we also do have a nice photo from
this tournament there you have it I did
some checking up and although it's hard
to make out a lot as it's not a great
quality photo I managed to deduce which
round it was from it's from round 11
actually on the board one you can see
that capablanca with the black pieces
faces Oscar has his opponent from the
previous round if you remember he lost
in the rice Memorial Tournament in 1916
to him and then
we mentioned a couple Blanca will go on
his legendary streak then behind them
you can see their young off ski faces
Frank James Marshall Marshall with the
black pieces and in the far away in the
back Morristown couple Uncas opponent
from this game and face a Serbian
Grandmaster borislav hostage so I do
hope you enjoyed that now let's check
out the game like we said it's again
from round three and capablanca opens
with d4 we have d5 and nice to f3 I just
before checking the game I would just
like to show you a neat little trick
that couple Blanca even mentions himself
in in the book sorry in the book just
fundamentals and I've actually witnessed
this happened over the board when we
were playing in our creation club
championship if you remember dodo the
engine boy from my stream he actually
got this position with the black pieces
east six five c3 Knight f6 and now if
white was Bishop to g5 Knight bt7
now white actually can go for OKC
capture Sun d5 pawn captures but then
white blundered with Knight captures on
d5 and it's hard to know that this is a
blunder if you don't know it or if you
don't or if you're not well if you're a
beginner this might come to you as a
surprise but black can actually
temporarily give up the Queen here with
Knight captures now after white captures
the Queen Bishop to b4 check and the
White has no defense he has to block the
check with the Queen Bishop captures
screen captures and now after King
captures here if you count the pieces
you will see that black has three minor
pieces of white has only only two minor
pieces so it's a winning game for black
but it's very interesting that such a
thing can occur I mean when I was
reading cover Blancas chess fundamental
so I found this very well very enjoyable
so I do hope you enjoyed it as well but
getting back to this game kappa blanka
continues with knight to f3 with Knight
to f6 now c4 and d6 we are back at the
queen of Queens gambit declined Bishop
to g5 with Bishop to e7
now comes Knight to c3 and here well you
might go for something like Knight bb7
but here now morrison goes for c5
immediately and it's not a mistake or
anything it's it's perfectly playable
move
I don't know if you if you consider
chess principles then c5 is usually
played in for example in the Queen's
Gambit the client when white develops
the Bishop to f4
because when the bishop is in g5 the
bishop actively fights for the center as
it it attacks one of the defenders of
the central pawn so a c5 usually a best
idea when the bishop is on f4 but I
guess it's also playable here but ok D
captures and c5 by capablanca now black
will have to waste a move as he already
developed the bishop Buda Bishop to e7
but Morrison goes for Queen to a5 he now
threatens to win back at the pawn this
way but he's not actually going for the
point he's just pinning the knight here
also there are some nice ideas the
knight is pinned maybe if this Knight
moves you can also play d4 maybe travel
tonight but it's a very active play from
blacks perspective seek after Sundy 5 by
Capablanca he captures and now comes a
III just preventing any sneaky ideas
from black preparing to develop the
better Bishop to b5 is the idea with
nice the c6 rook to c1 by kappa blanka
and now castles by Morrison and Bishop
to b5 here a couple bunkers actually
preparing Queen to a4 he's currently up
upon and black decides not to recapture
his pawn because if he recaptures Bishop
captures here he no longer defends the
night here Capablanca would gladly
capture here and after pawn captures
even grab this d5 pawn so black would be
in big trouble here so first with Bishop
to g4 by Morrison and now Queen to a4
and here black has to react to this if
you don't react the Queen a4 let's say
you try something like h6 again you
would get a bunch of captures and now
let's say Queen captures first bishop
captures Bishop captures on f6 you no
longer defended the sefa attack the c5
pawn with your bishop just Knight
captures on d5 Bishop captures on b2 now
rook c2 we don't want to allow the trip
to c3 check Bishop captures pawn
captures and after Bishop here the white
would be up a pawn and it would be a
positional winning game for white just
kinky - you can go rogue b1 the b7 point
is very weak and in the long run
called witness so after Queen a4 by
Capablanca Morrison captures it Queen
captures with a nightcap resume for now
further defending the pawn here
preparing B for Bishop captures an f3 in
giving up the bishop pair but messing up
White's pawn structure the pawn captures
on G on f3 and now Knight to e5 going
after the f3 pawn with King to e2 kappa
blanka defends it and now rook a to c8
and B for by kappa blanka cementing that
pawn on c5 and if you look at this
position what does black have to show
for his lack of a pawn not all that much
but ok b6 and here capablanca finds a
very nice move f4 first he forces black
to decide what to do with the night and
there isn't all that much you can do
with the night for example if Knight
here just captures and you lose a piece
the bishop on e7 is unguarded so with
nice to g6 and only now kappa blanka
proceeds with donkey after Sun v6 with
Bishop captures on b4 first a capture
son B was probably probably a little bit
better but ok rush of capture some
before with Bishop captures on f6
opening up the G file very important
pawn captures enter now B captures on a
7 by kappa blanka look to a8
hoping to win this pawn here and now a
nice in-between move by Capablanca rook
H to g1 now you can see that the f4 move
was very handy f5 is coming and even
though a f5 is a threat of winning
tonight there really isn't a good way of
preventing this black did the fender
with a king to h8 he did not allow the
knight to be trapped but just rook
captures an a7 is a much sturdier
defense even though black is lost or
whatever whatever black plays but
Morrison didn't want to give up his
knife he played King to h8 and now we
have looked a c7 with a pretty simple
idea
the point is defended you want to play
Bishop to c6 kick away the rook play
pawn to 88 Queen the pawn and black
would have to give up rope for a bishop
and cover Blanca would have a winning
game so with Bishop to a5
attacking the rook and also not allowing
nice to b6 rook to b7 and now
rook F the c8 but now
Kabongo plays Bishop to d3 he doesn't
want to allow any contra play with rook
to c2 so he just blocks it but also here
a couple Blanca misses a very nice
opportunity to be to be funny because he
also could have blocked it with Bishop
to c6 it's a very nice idea because if
rook capture Syria just go rugby a trick
and of course black will not capture
black who will block with the rook but
now rook b1 and now again you're
threatening rook captures here and
there's not all that much you can do or
even even without this you can first
capture capture and then go rugby want
even even simpler again threatening rook
to b8 black it doesn't really have a
good response to this if if Bishop to c7
rook the c1 and that's pretty much it if
King g7 just rook captures on c7 and
it's all over if you capture then pony
it is a queen if rook to e8 just Knight
b6 and it's a lot of rook has to move
you will win the rope with a eight or
just captures captures without
completely winning endgame so Bishop to
d3 Capablanca goes for the simplest idea
but much of the c6 was also very nice
funny move but okay nice to a fate
morrison prepares to well reintroduce
this knight into the game
rook G to be one now preparing rook to
b8 as the knight is now a target on the
last rank King to g7 defending the
knight and now just rook to b5 attacking
the bishop here rook the c7 saying if
you win my bishop I'm going to take your
rook but just a rook captures kappa
blanka again keeps it simple Bishop
captures on c7 and now rook to b7
just attacking that Bishop Bishop to a5
and now comes f5 just you know improving
the position as a black doesn't have all
that many active moves with h5 by black
and the now h4 King to h6 giving up the
f7 pawn but it's really interesting if
you look at this position sort of a tube
swung nuts not really a perfect too
strong but black doesn't really have a
good move you can't move the bishop any
more with the bishop will capture it you
could go Bishop here but that's not
really a move the bishop isn't doing
anything there white can just go back up
C to Bishop b3 window d5 pawn
and then start pushing his pawns and
from d5 double shot and the rook will
pile up on the f7 point so that's not
really an option
the knight nowhere to go you can go
night h7 but the night from h7 doesn't
have a good square the rook cannot move
if the rook moves then rook b8 wins so
not not any not a lot of moves I mean
there are moves you can go night h7 but
it's not doing anything so it cut it is
a took swung but King h6 was played
giving up the f7 pawn kappa blanka said
okay thank you sir and here I guess we
have another example where black 2 just
didn't want to resign prior to move 30
so it couldn't be categorized as a
miniature I guess as there is a really
no comfortable here from blacks
perspective d4 was played maybe trying
to mess up White's pawn structure but
couple Blanca just went nuts up to d4
which was the initial idea just trying
to kick away the rook from there we have
d3 check King captures and it was in
this position that Jon Stewart Morrison
resigned the game unmoved 32 because he
could have easily resigned a move 29 for
example nobody now you have to move the
rook and then phone Queens you have to
go through or you capture capture and
there's no counter play here White is
just up a piece completely winning even
with the past a point it will be much
quicker so that's it after King captures
Morrison resigned the game and an
excellent victory for Capablanca so he
defeated Marshall in the epic game in
round 1 then a draw would roll into
Reuter Merle black in round 2 and then
an excellent victory against Jon Stewart
Morrison in round 3 so we are continuing
with this tournament it was supposed to
be an eight-player event but then one
player got sick and cancelled at the
last time and then turned into a 7
player event and it's always a problem
when you have a 7 player event one
player will always have to chill every
day because well he will not have an
opponent but I guess he can just you
know walk around and enjoy the position
yeah I believe in this photo that we've
seen the person not having an opponent
in this front is Roy - Umbra black as he
is not present amongst those playing so
he could be one of the people you know
watching them but I can't spot him it's
it's simply too poor of
quality photo but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and I do hope you
enjoyed the this direction I've taken
that Capablanca saga and so first we're
gonna check this New York 1918
tournament as I feel it will be a nice
introduction to the match against
Borislav Kostich in 1919 and then we are
heading into the World Chess
Championship match couple Monica versus
Emmanuel Lasker so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Ton Ton Mugen carlos salinas
steven painting gary bucks todd and
roman finta for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos your thing called for watching
and I will see soon hopefully with some
more interesting content continuing the
Capablanca saga and of course checking
up on your suggestions think oh I will
see you soon have an excellent rest of
your Monday
[Music]